well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight the president literally
throughout the script today he went down
to West Virginia to speak in an event
that was supposed to be about tax reform
but he wound up talking about
immigration instead here's part of it
with us it's a lottery system pick them
out a lottery system you can imagine
what those countries put into the system
they're not putting their good ones and
remember my opening remarks at Trump
Tower when I opened everybody said all
he was so tough and I used the word rape
and yesterday it came out where this
journey coming up women are raped at
levels that nobody has ever seen before
they don't want to mention that well
that lines leading the nightly news
across the country tonight here in
Washington it drove people completely
crazy how dare he tie immigration to
rape that's slander
obviously it's racist he's not allowed
to say that there's one CNN
correspondent put it a minute ago
Trump quote doesn't tie himself to
standards of fact and objectivity he
simply decides to say these things maybe
he saw them on Fox News or watching Alex
Jones his habit is to repeat them
regardless of them being consistently
disproven okay maybe he saw that on Fox
maybe Trump was reading The Huffington
Post actually because just a few years
ago before they started lying full-time
the people in charge were slightly less
anxious to change the subject here for
example is a verbatim September 2014
headline from HuffPo quote 80% of
Central American women and girls are
raped crossing into the u.s. 80 percent
so yes there are rapists out there
uncomfortable is that fact maybe for
some to admit immigration affects Public
Safety and anyone who denies that is
ignorant or dishonest and yet a lot of
people do deny it
confront them with reality and they call
you names they denounce you diversity is
our strength they screech as if that
settles the conversation by itself like
a magic talisman they don't want to know
the details facts are a threat to their
fantasies they don't want you to know
the details either shut up and obey
those are their orders but no matter
what they say facts don't go away they
persist despite official attempts to
erase them and here
some facts about the state of California
Democratic senator Kamala Harris has
called her state the future of America
and she may be right
California has for generations been on
the leading edge of national trends in
this country so looking at California
what does it tell us about our future
well in California right now more than
6% of the entire state is there
illegally that's about two and a half
million people a million of those have
state driver's licenses politicians in
California are very proud of that fact
that is issued a press release to brag
about what a great place California is
for illegal aliens and by the way
they're right compared to a haka it is a
great place that's way better but what
is California like for everyone else
forty-four percent of Californians now
do not speak English at home the state
no longer has a common language or a
common culture its infrastructure is
collapsing debt is out of control
schools are unusable public spaces are
filthy the middle class is fleeing
California for all of those reasons
normal people can't live there anymore
in 2016 more than a hundred thousand
Californians left housing prices are out
of control wages are too low to keep up
the state increasingly consists of
technology arcs and their imported
low-wage servants that's the point
California is developing the economic
structure of Latin America how long
before it's venezuela you're not
supposed to think about any of that our
leaders command you not to send the
National Guard to protect the borders
why would we do that as Morning Joe
reminded us just today border crossings
are down but that's a lie like much of
what you hear right now it's untrue last
month more than 50,000 illegal
immigrants were caught at our border
that's three times as many as were
apprehended in the same month last year
things are getting better go to
California and see for yourself as
Pamela Harris says it's our future
Allen irani is executive director of the
national immigration forum and he joins
us tonight so here so just a broad
question and I'm glad you're back you've
been on the show a number of times
you've made the case it's a it's a
pretty common case that immigration
low-skilled emigration included makes us
richer if that is true what is a state
with the highest number of immigrants
legal and illegal the highest proportion
of immigrants now have more poverty than
any other state and is almost a trillion
dollars in debt why isn't it working
there
well in California you have an economy
that as a sixth largest economy in the
world and I'm not gonna say the
California doesn't have its share of
challenges but those challenges are not
to be laid at the feet of the immigrant
community there are challenges that come
with a fast growing economy that is you
know quite frankly presenting challenges
for everybody so there are a lot of
policy changes that can be put into
place to help everybody prosper in
California but let's not you know nobody
but you're sort of I'm not blaming
anybody I'm actually asking you to
defend the argument that you've made on
this show and that many others like you
make every day which is that America
becomes more prosperous because of our
immigration policy here's the state that
has more immigrants than any other and
it's getting poorer so I'd like you to
ask I'd like to ask you to account for
your position if you would so when you
look at the agricultural community in
California it is easily the largest
agricultural sector in the country that
has driven by and large by the immigrant
community the rest of the country has a
hard time eating without the Mexican
look that's not true that's not that's
not true California Agriculture's become
increasingly mechanized over the years
I'm from there I bag people in my family
there it requires less labor now and it
did 15 years ago and I thought when I
talked to growers in California they're
looking for labor to pick crops such as
strawberries melons these are not across
that you can pick with them with the
Machine kentucker
I mean you know that so strawberries are
one of the few crops that you can't look
agriculture needs labor I'm not denying
that I'm just saying it means less labor
than it did 50 years ago yet the state
has farmed with one of their ones and
why then why that's why our growers
looking for there because their growers
actually leaving crops in the ground
because I'm attacking their their water
problems in California their land use
product a lot of problems in California
labor is one of them but the truth is
you have argued consistently on this
show that letting in more people from
other countries with low education
levels will make us richer we have a
case study in stark relief called
California and the opposite has happened
so I really think the onus is on you to
give a real explanation not tell me that
agriculture brings a lot of poor people
and that's not true and you know it's
not true
so what happens in California again the
six largest economy in the country is
that you have immigrants who are coming
working alongside American workers and
their families whether it's in the tech
sector or in the agricultural sector in
both sectors immigrants are helping
create jobs in California
I mean Tucker you're trying to lay in
ramzan cha doing it is asking oh no no
what I'm asking for is an adult
conversation what if just one others no
because you're not you told me you
literally just stared to the camera like
I'm some kind of [ __ ] and said it's the
AG sector that's driving immigration to
California I know the numbers that's not
even untrue it's ridiculous so here's my
other question in California is a
paradise good why is the middle class
leaving why did a hundred thousand
people move last year over a seven-year
period six hundred and seventy five
thousand more people moved to other
states from California they moved into
California why does that happen this is
a chat because in California you have a
USA that has or a state that has all
these incredible land use and zoning
issues that you just talked about Tucker
again this is not a problem that is at
the immigrant communities feet this is a
problem that is facing California
overall and this is what comes these are
the challenges that comes with such
amazing and economic growth these
amazing people who are born they're
leaving let me ask you one last question
since I don't think you're gonna concede
that immigration is any role in any of
this which with respect is dishonest and
we both know it is but let me ask you
this
Oh irrefutable 44% of California
households do not speak English at home
does that bother you at all do you think
that long term that suggests problems
ahead a state in which there's no common
language do you think that possibly
could cause problems there so when you
when you talk to educators when you talk
to families across the state of
California you see that they are looking
to learn English because they understand
that in order if they learn English they
get a better job their children get a
better lot in life so the fact is that
the immigrant community in California
and across the country is waiting in
line to learn English I mean why is that
number rising every year every year you
have a higher percentage of pot of
households in California that don't
speak English so if what you said is
true why is that fact true because both
can't be true because you have because
you have more and more people who are
looking to actually learn the language
which is I think the the Ultem
way to become American hmm hmm magic
okay I'm sorry
look I just want to have a fact-based
conversation nobody else does
you're a racist or whatever but like
this is real this is how much I'm sure
no I didn't say that don't sucker don't
let's not put words in our mouths I mean
I don't think that you said that and I
didn't mean to suggest that you took in
that I didn't but many people say that
and it lets short-circuits the
conversation anyway I like thank you for
coming on I appreciate it thank